خلقنا النطفه علقه فخلقنا العلقه مضغى
فخلقنا المضغه عظاما فكسونا العظام لحما
ثم انشاناه
خلقا اخر
فتبارك الله
فتبارك الله احسن الخالقين
ثم انكم
بعد ذلك لميتون
ثم انكم يوم القيامه تبعثون
ولقد خلقنا فوقكم سبع طرائق
وما كنا عن الخلق غافلين
وانزلنا
من السماء
ماء
بقدر
فاسكناه
في الارض وانا على ذهاب به لقادرون
فانشانا
به فانشانا
لكم به جنات
جنات
من نخيل واعناب
لكم فيها فواكه كثيره
ومنها تاكلون
وشجره
تخرج من طور سيناء
تنبت بالدهن وصبغ للاكلين
وان لكم في الانعام لعبره
نسقيكم مما في بطونها
ولكم فيها منافع كثيره
ومنها تاكلون
وعليها وعلى الفلك تحملون
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ولقد ارسلنا نوحا الى قومه فقال يا قوم
اعبدوا الله ما لكم من اله غيره
افلا تتقون
فقال الملاء الذين كفروا
من قومه ما هذا الا بشر مثلكم
هذا بشر مثلكم يريد ان يتفضل عليكم
ولو شاء
الله لانزل ملائكه
ما سمعنا بهذا في ابائنا
الاولين
ان هو الا رجل به جنه فتربصوا به حتى حين
قال رب انصرني
بما كذبون
فاوحينا اليه ان اصنع الفلك باعيننا
ووحينا
اصنع الفلك باعيننا ووحي نا فاذا جاء
امرنا وفارت
النور فاسلك فيها
فاسلك فيها من كل زوجين اثنين واهلك الا
من سبق عليه القول منهم
ولا تخاطبني في الذين ظلموا انهم
مغرقون
فاذا اذا استويت انت ومن معك على الفلك
فقل الحمد لله
فقل الحمد لله الذي نجانا من القوم
الظالمين
وقل رب انزلني
منزل صدق وانت خير المنزلين
المبارك
وقل رب انزلني
منزلا
مباركا
وانت خير المنزلين
ان في ذلك لايات
وان كنا لمبتلين
ثم انشانا
من بعدهم قرنا اخرين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
الصلوات الطيبات والسلام
الله
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم خير المخطاب عليهم
الضالين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
اشهد ان محمد
رسول اللهم صل على
[Silence]
ش
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله استغفر الله استغفر
السلام
[Silence]
‏want to just reflect on what we exp to
those of you
may not have the
pray in this mask we exp something very
funding for ourad
so which was announced
‏question
estad
schம
‏and we would to
would to make sure that we have
space in the coming year so we are we
haveed
a one parcel on this
and that will be used for the start of a
new rahy building and going to be a for
the community for this তাকবর
তাকবর
ফন্মাস
আলহামদুলিল্লাহি রাব্বিল আলামিন
ர000
তাকবল
‏resp
and want to apprate
everybody and
we were able to reach milestone
defin our need is high and as you can we
going build on a parcel we going have
something be more just apprম
7 8000
plus s of space that we going to
construct with 12 to 15 classro spac so
be ma
so the budget is pry high we have not
you know established all theil but what
you have done today is encouraging us
to a lel that i so excited that
‏So
something needing
from us the other one
is this message to other lo you have any
of your friends the people who may not
this pleas get the message to them there
is participate in a real that
‏et soport
take opportun
this sch you will be
cle of other things
willday
night ‏So it's going to be the after we
finish the prayer on is on Monday we
will have
here and the next morning
prov the and
starts at 4
and
so our start at 4 445
‏try to schle as much as can so those
have pray here and go home and the
us enough time to do that and those want
to stay here and do it we provide the
support for everybodyই
again the general things pleas drive
carefully as much as you ‏can try to
keep the traffic you know around the
building as contr as you can because
there are some incidents where we have
seen people just driving a little b to f
andinder has to be that are kids around
the building and of course not the area
is not well all the way around some dark
spones
around the buildings so pleas be
carefulلام
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
‏have to
worm
theek with
and
prop andination
and how the is insulate himself from
this how the is insulate herself from
this and how our prop
us to
‏up
for this I want you to
something with me
here in this are this neorh this small
if you will imagine we have a dedicated
school
that can take a Muslim
‏all the
sch
all the graduation
with
that
areing up scho children up down this
here
after scho at the scho and
‏sch
boys and com backرademy
willingر
[Silence]
‏hereicated
the words of toy
verbat
you know a lot of times I've traveled so
much been all over the world I've
studied and taught all over the east and
west and one thing that you hear all the
time is anywh you go which is kind of
human nature is anywh you
‏will sit you down
me down
and give me a long heroic story of all
of their
legendary
fantastical accomplishments. ‏I was
here back in when when wagons were being
pulled by horses and there was no one
but me and I did this and I made this
whole place and this community is
perfect and everything we do here is
perfect and look how many buildings we
have and look how many
it's the same story every you go yeah
sure people to take pride in the
accish that theyve made but here's
really a l test ‏for accomplishment.
It's not how many
students we have enrolled in the school.
It's not how many buildings we have.
It's not how many people come to attend
Jum.
It's not how much money we make from
donations.
It's not even
how recognized we are by the local or
state or even government. ‏These are not
the whole marks of accomplishment.
One question that you can ask
to
act as a litmus test on a community
success
or general failure
one question.
‏How many stud of knowledge how
of the quar
have youuced
this is the test someone we have comm 30
40 50 years and we still knowledge from
abroad
think about it we still bring even the
of our own we bringing
‏comm
and arch engineers and driving lat s mod
mercedes and bmws and we can
‏on any
right but if we have not inspired our
children enough for them to desire to
stud learn and memor the book of Allah
what is the point of all this
and that's where we need to put our
focus
we need to put our focus into our childr
‏stops with us
I don't know who is murmuring
extremely distracting am I you sure
and so
it is absutelytical
‏What is that we need to have? You know
this kind of
Muslim
moderately Muslim you know we don't want
to become to Muslim you don't want that.
You just want to be a little bit Muslim.
‏You know what I mean?
We just want to make sure that we don't
any toes with our Islam just be a Musl
in my closet at home, right?
And I come to the
day but my daughters they don't hij my
son they don't pray. They don't come to
the all doctors and lawyers and
architects. Great. But we haven inspired
them enough.
‏to to
this
to you know why because
over
are time prop himself
described as a man will be in the
morning a believer
and the will not set on him until he is
a disbeliever
صلى الله عليه وسلم بادروا
بالاعمال
قطعا
فتنا كقطع الليل المظلم
يصبح الرجل فيها مؤمنا ويمسي كافرا او
يمسي الرجل مؤمنا ويصبح كافرا
يبيع دينه بعرض من الدنيا
dark
are so
‏that a man will be a believer in the
morning and a disbeliever by nightfall.
‏Or be a believer at nightfall a
disbeliever by sunrise he will trade
hisigion
for something of the whatever it is.
Now how does that happen? That happens
from weakness in knowledge,
weakness in resolve weakness in
community
where a person can be amongst us one day
disappear and nobody really asks about
him.
‏What happen to
and the customer mentality I come to
this but I have to be served the
customer and the customer always right
and if I don't one thing I have a
bad experience I'm not going there any
no I'll go to the next
my kids they used to be in the school
but you know what that school I came I
told they had
‏up and I told about they take it down
took my kids right out there
now your kids can go and listen to aing
of my two in the school what are we do
here this is not commity and this is
notceptable it has to stop with us a
challeng
has failed if he doesn't stud knowledge
‏fail
no matter how build the prop صلى الله
عليه وسلم the ground of wasebles and
dirt it noingcept
where the st and coule of the first
ج
branches
on to the bricks made out of mud
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
عشجر ‏Why? If you're not there, no's
going to see that you're not there. You
pray and you don't even know who
standing next to you. They didn't have
in the
but he sat in that under those
conditions and he said to his
companions,
"This religion will reach whever the day
and night reach."
‏under thoseen
stones
from aching ofunger
that falling
in
malnut
and sit there and say thisigion from a
little in the midle of the desert will
reach whever the day and have reach
‏comecy
come
atend
with their sweat with their tear
‏have
you hereight
and look
this we have here both thems of narting
to
i myselfiting
رخ
محمد صلى الله عليه
‏moreanc
are
the
vulnerable and among us which are
you let them go into that blender out
there and mi with wild
that ar sure if a man or
‏if
notur any
if you them to grow upend
don't think you won be asked about that
and have your
and so having said that we will end we
went a little over time but this is for
theent of our academy be back on
schedule tomorrow frid i'm gear
10ush
have few extra minut
is
this
for because زكاه one of
tyes of the sword
‏away
that
up mind that means there
we have this today we have the we have
the pieces we need to do it we have
those among us
‏have us are take
and
everyle
a payment could
it could
peanuts to us
you make it with the rest of the bills
of your house you haveills youay netfli
right youay apple
‏least
take upon yourself I will not hereight
without having a plan of giv
every one of us every single one of us
and if we do
‏will have
another car you
glob with all of it will be accounted
for this is what we are do this for we
have this we
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا
نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان يعصمنا وان يعصم
ابنائنا وبناتنا والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا
[Silence]
بسم
بسم الله الرحمن
[Silence]
الله
استقيم واعتدل استووا سو الصف سد الخلل
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط
الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ان في ذلك لايات
وان كنا لمبتلين
ثم انشانا من بعدهم قرنا اخرين
فارسلنا فيهم رسولا منهم ان اعبدوا الله
ما لكم من اله غيره
افلا تتقون
وقال الملا الذين كفروا من قوم
وقال الملا من قومه الذين كفروا وكذبوا
وكذبوا بلقاء الاخره واترفناهم في الحياه
الدنيا ما هذا
ما هذا الا بشر
مثلكم
ياكل مما تاكلون منه ويشرب مما تشربون
ولئن اطعتم بشرا مثلكم انكم اذا لخاسرون
ايعدكم انكم اذا متم وكنتم ترابا
وعظاما انكم مخرجون
هيهات هيهات لما توعدون
ان هي الا حياتنا الدنيا نموت ونحيا وما
نحن بمبعوثين
ان هو الا رجل افترى على الله كذبا وما
نحن له بمؤمنين
قال رب انصرني بما كذبون
قال عما قليل ليسن
نادمين
فاخذتهم الصيحه بالحق فجعلناهم غثاء
فبعدا للقوم الظالمين
ثم انشانا من بعدهم قرونا اخرين
ما تسبق من امه اجلها وما يستاخرون
ثم ارسلنا رسلنا تترا
كلما جاء امه رسولها كذبوه
فاتبعنا بعضهم بعضا وجعلناهم
احاديث
فبعدا لقوم لا يؤمنون
ثم ارسلنا موسى واخاه هارون باياتنا
وسلطان
مبين
الى فرعون وملائه فاستكبروا
فاستكبروا وكانوا قوما عاملين فقالوا
انؤمن لبشرين مثلنا وقومهما لنا عابدون
فكذبوهما
فكانوا من المهلكين
ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب لعلهم يهتدون
وجعلنا ابن مريم وامه
ايه واويناهما
واويناهما
الى ربوه ذات قرار ومعين
يا ايها الرسل كلوا من الطيبات واعملوا
صالحا
اني
بما تعملون عليم
وان هذه امتكم
امه واحده
وانا ربكم فاتقون
فتقطعوا بينهم امرهم زبرا
كل حزب
بما لديهم فرحون
فقطعوا
امرهم بينهم زبرا كل حزب بما لديهم فرحون
فذرهم في غمرتهم حتى حين ايحسبون
انما نمدهم
به من مال وبنين
نسارع لهم في الخيرات
نسارع لهم في الخيرات بل لا يشعرون
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ان الذين هم من خشيه ربهم مشفقون
والذين هم بايات ايات ربهم يؤمنون
والذين هم بربهم لا يشركون
والذين اتوا والذين يؤتون ما اتوابهم
وجله انهم
الى ربهم راجعون
اولئك
يسارعون في الخيرات وهم لها سابقون
ولا نكلف نفسا الا وسعها
ولدينا كتاب ينطق بالحق وهم لا يظلمون
بل قلوبهم في غمره من هذا ولهم اعمال من
دون ذلك هم لها عاملون
حتى اذا اخذنا متر فيهم بالعذاب
اذا هم يجارون
لا تجاروا اليوم انكم مما لا تنصرون
قد كانت اياتي تتلى عليكم فكنتم على
اعقابكم تنكصون
مستكبرين به سامرا
تهجرون
افلم يدبروا القول ام جاءهم
ما لم يات اباءهم
الاولين
افلم يعرفوا ام لم يعرفوا رسولهم فهم له
منكرون
ام يقولون به جنه بل جاء
بالحق واكثرهم للحق كارهون
ولو اتبع الحق حق اهواءهم
لفسدت السماوات والارض
لفسدت السماوات والارض ومن فيهن
بل جئناهم
بل اتيناهم
بالحق واكثرهم كارهون
بذكرهم فهم عن ذكرهم معرض ضون ام تسالهم
خرجا فخراج ربك خير وهو خير الرازقين
ام تساله خرجا فخراج ربك خير
وهو خير الرازقين
وانك لتدعوهم الى صراط مستقيم
وان الذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره
عن الصراط لناكبون
ولو رحمناهم وكشفنا ما بهم من ضر للجوا في
طغيانهم يعمهون
للجوا في طغيانهم يعمهون
ولقد اخذناهم بالعذاب فما استكانوا لربهم
وما يتضرعون
حتى اذا فتحنا عليهم بابا ذا عذاب شديد
ذا عذاب شديد اذا هم فيه مبلسون
وهو الذي انشاكم
وجعل لكم السمع والابصار والافئده
قليلا ما تشكرون
وهو الذي انشا لكم السمع والابصار
والافئده
قليلا ما تشكرون
وهو الذي ذراكم في الارض واليه تحشرون
وهو الذي يحيي ويميت وله اختلاف الليل
والنهار
افلا عقلون
بل قالوا مثلما قال الاولون
قالوا ائذا متنا وكنا ترابا وعظاما اانا
لمبعوثون
لقد وعدنا نحن واباؤنا
هذا من قبل ان هذا الا اساطير الاولين
قل لمن الارض ومن فيها ان كنتم تعلمون
سيقولون لله قل افلا تذكرون
قل من رب السماوات السبع ورب العرش العظيم
سيقولون لله
سيقولون
لله قل افلا تتقون
قل من بيده ملكوت كل شيء وهو يجير ولا
يجار عليه
وهو يجير ولا يجار عليه ان كنتم تعلمون
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكثر
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
سلام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
قل من بيده ملكوت كل شيء وهو يجير ولا
يجار عليه ان كنتم تعلمون
سيقولون لله قل فانا تسحر
بل اتيناهم
بالحق وانهم لكاذبون
ما اتخذ الله من ولد وما كان معه من اله
اذا لذهب كل اله بما خلق ولعلى بعضهم على
بعض سبحان سبحانه عما يشر ركون
عالم الغيب والشهاده فتعالى عنه سبحانه
عما يصفون
عالم الغيب والشهاده فتعالى عما يشركون
وقل رب انا تريني ما يوعدون
رب فلا تجعلني في القوم الظالمين
وانا على ان نريعدهم
لقادرون
ادفع بالتي هي احسن السيئه
نحن اعلم بما يصفون
وقل رب اعوذ بك من همزات الشياطين واعوذ
بك رب ان يحضرون
حتى اذا جاء احدهم الموت قال رب ارجعون
قال رب ارجعوني لعلي اعمل صالحا فيما تركت
كلا انها كلمه هو قائلها
ومن ورائهم
برزخ الى يوم يبعثون
فاذا نفخ في الصور فلا انساب بينهم يومئذ
ولا يتساءلون
فاما من ثقلت موازينه
فاولئك
هم المفلحون
ومن خفت موازينه
فاولئك
الذين خسروا انفسهم
في جهنم خالدون
تلفح وجو
هم النار وهم فيها كالحون
الم تكن اياتي تتلى عليكم فكنتم
بها تكذبون
قالوا ربنا ظلت علينا شقوتنا وكنا قوم
ضالين
ربنا اخرجنا منها فان عدنا
ربنا اخرجنا منها فان عدنا فانا ظالمون
قال اخسؤوا فيها ولا تكلمون
انه كان فريق من عبادي يقولون ربنا امنا
يقولون ربنا امنا فاغفر لنا وارحمنا
وانت خير الراحمين
فاتخذتموهم
سخريا حتى انسوكم ذكري وكنتم
منهم تضحكون
اني جزيتهم اليوم بما صبروا
اني جزيتهم اليوم بما صبروا انهم هم الفا
قال كم لبثتم في الارض عدد سنين قالوا
لبثنا يوما او بعض يوم فاسال العادين
قال بل لبثتم الا قليلا لو انكم كنتم
تعلمون
افحسبتم انما ما خلقناكم
عبثا
وانكم الينا لا ترجعون
فتعالى الله الملك الحق لا اله الا هو رب
العرش الكريم
ومن يدع مع الله الها اخر لا برهان له به
فانما
حسابه
عند ربه انه لا يفلح الكافرون
انه لا يفلح الكافرون
وقل رب اغفر وارحم وانت
خير الراحمين
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك اياك
نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
سوره انزلناها
وفرضناها
وانزلنا فيها ايات بينات لعلكم تذكرون
الزانيه والزاني فاجلدوا كل واحد منهما
100ه جلده ولا تاخذكم بهما رافه في دين
الله ان كنتم تؤمنون بالله واليوم الاخر
وليشهد عذابهما طائفه
من المؤمنين
الزاني لا ينكح الا زانيه او مشركه
والزانيه لا ينكحها
الا زان او مشرك وحرم ذلك على المؤمنين
والذين يرمون المحصن
ثم لم ياتوا باربعه شهداء فاجلدوهم
فاجلدوهم 80 جلده ولا تقبلوا لهم شهاده
ابدا واولئك
هم الفاسقون
الا الذين تابوا من بعد ذلك
واصلحوا فان الله فان الله غفور رحيم
والذين يرمون ازواجهم ولم يكن لهم شهداء
الا انفسهم
فشهاده احدهم اربع شهادات
بالله انه لمن الصادقين
والخامسه ان لعنه الله عليه ان كان من
الكاذبين
ويدر عنها العذاب ان تشهد اربع شهادات
بالله انه لمن الكاذبين
والخامسه ان غضب الله عليها ان كان من
الصادقين
ولولا فضل الله عليكم ورحمته
وان الله تواب حكيم
ان الذين جاءوا بالافك عصبه منكم لا
تحسبوه شرا لكم بل هو خير لكم لكل امر
منهم ما اكتسب من الاثم
والذي تولى كبره منهم له عذاب عظيم لولا
اذ سمعتموه ظن المؤمنون والمؤمنات
انفسهم خيرا
وقالوا هذا افق مبين
لولا جاؤوا عليه باربعه شهداء
فان لم ياتوا بالشهداء
فاولئك
هم فاولئك
عند الله هم الكاذبون
ولولا فضل الله عليكم ورحمته لمسكم
لمسكم فيما افضتم فيه عذاب عظيم
ولولا فضل الله عليكم ورحمته في الدنيا
والاخره
لمسكم فيما افضتم فيه عذاب عظيم اذ تلقونه
بالسنتكم
اذ تلقونه
بالسنتكم وتقولون بافواهكم
ما ليس لكم به علم وتحسبونه
هينا وهو عند الله عظيم
ولولا اذ سمعتموه قلتم ما يكون لنا ان
نتكلم بهذا
سبحانك هذا بهتان عظيم يعد كم الله ان
تعودوا لمثله ابدا ان كنتم مؤمنين
ويبين الله لكم الايات
والله عليم حكيم
ان الذين يحبون ان تشيع الفاحشه في الذين
امنوا لهم عذاب اليم في الدنيا
والاخره
والله يعلم وانتم
لا تعلمون
ولولا فضل الله عليكم ورحمته
وان
الله تواب رحيم
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
عندك الايه
حكي الايه عندك الاخير الايه عندك الاخيره
[Arabic recitation]
نعب ايضا
لا شبين شويه
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ولولا فضل الله عليكم ورحمته وان الله
رؤوف رحيم
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تتبعوا خطوات
الشيطان
ومن يتبع خطوات الشيطان فانه يامر
بالفحشاء
والمنكر
ولولا فضل الله عليكم ورحمته ما زكى منكم
من احد ابدا ولكن الله يزكي من يشاء
والله سميع عليم
ولا ياتلولو الفضل منكم والسعه ان يؤتوا
اولي القربى والمساكين والمهاجرين في سبيل
الله وليعفوا وليصفحوا
الا تحبون ان يغفر الله لكم والله غفور
رحيم
ان الذين يرمون المحصنات الغافلات
المؤمنات لعنوا في الدنيا والاخره ولهم
عذاب عظيم عظيم يوم تشهد عليهم السنتهم
وايديهم وارجلهم بما كانوا يعملون
يومئذ يوفيهم الله دينهم الحق ويعلمون ان
الله هو الحق المبين
الخبيثات للخبيثين والخبيثون للخبيثات
والطيبات للطيبين والطيبون للطيبات
اولئك مبرون مما يقولون لهم مغفره ورزق
كريم
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تدخلوا بيوتا غير
بيوتكم حتى تستانسوا وتسلموا على اهلها
ذلكم خير لكم لعلكم تذكرون
فان لم تجدوا فيها احدا فلا تدخلوها حتى
يؤذن لكم وان قيل لكم ارجعوا فارجعوا هو
ازكى لكم
والله بما تعملون عليم
ليس عليكم جناح ان تدخلوا بيوتا غير
مسكونه فيها متاع لكم والله يعلم ما تبدون
وما تكتمون
قل للمؤمنين يغضوا من ابصارهم ويحفظوا
فروجهم ذلك ازكى لهم ان الله خبير بما
يصنعون
وقل للمؤمنات يغضن من ابصارهن
ويحفظن فروجهن ولا يبدين زينتهن
الا ما ظهر منها
وليضربن بخمرهن على جيوبهن ولا يبدين
زينتهن
الا لبعولتهن
او ابائهن
او اباء بعولتهن
او اباء بعولتهن او ابنائهن
او ابناء بعولتهن
او اخوانهن او بني اخوانهن او بني اخواتهن
او بني اخواتهن او نسائهن
او ما ملكت ايمانهن او التابعين غير اولي
الاربه من الرجال او الطفل الذين لم
يظهروا
او الطفل الذين لم يظهروا على عورات
النساء
ولا يضربن ولا يضربن بارجلهن
ليعلم ما يخفين من زينتهن
وتوبوا الى الله جميعا ايها المؤمنون
لعلكم تفلحون
وانكحوا الاياما منكم والصالحين من عبادكم
وامائكم
ان يكونوا فقراء يغنهم الله من فضله الله
واسع عليم
وليستعفف الذين لا يجدون نكاحا حتى يغنيهم
الله من فضله والذين يبتغون الكتاب مما
ملكت ايمانكم فكاتبوهم ان علمتم فيهم خيرا
واتوهم
واتوهم من مال الله الذي اتاكم
ولا تكرهوا فتياتكم على البغاء ان اردن
تحصنا لتبتغوا عرض الحياه الدنيا
ومن يكرههن فان الله من بعد اكراههن غفور
رحيم
ولقد انزلنا اليكم ايات مبينات
ولقد انزلنا اليكم ايات
مبينات
ومثلا من الذين خلوا من قبلكم وموعظه
للمتقين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[Arabic recitation]
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
الله نور السماوات والارض
مثل نوره كمشكاه فيها مصباح
المصباح في زجاجه
الزجاجه كانها كوكب ذري يوق قد من شجره
مباركه زيتونه لا شرقيه ولا غربيه
يكاد زيتها يضيء ولو لم تمسسه نار
نور على نور يهدي الله لنوره من يشاء
ويضرب الله الامثال للناس والله بكل شيء
عليم
في بيوت اذن الله ان ترفع ويذكر فيها اسمه
يسبح له فيها بالغدو والاصال
رجال لا تلهيهم تجاره ولا بيع عن ذكر الله
واقام الصلاه وايتاء
الزكاه يخافون يوما
يخافون يوما تتقلب فيه القلوب والابصار
ليجزيهم الله احسن ما عملوا ويزيدهم من
فضله والله يرزق من يشاء بغير حساب
والذين كفروا اعمالهم كسراب بقيعه يحسبه
الظمان ماء
حتى اذا جاءه لم يجده شيئا ووجد الله عنده
فوفاه حسابه
والله سريع الحساب
او كظلمات في بحر لجي
يغشاه موج من فوقه موج من فوقه سحاب
ظلمات بعضها فوق بعض اذا اخرج يده لم يكد
يراها ومن لم يجعل الله له نورا فما ما له
من نور
الم تر ان الله يسبح له من في السماوات
والارض والطير صافات
كل قد علم صلاته وتسبيحه
والله عليم بما يفعلون
ولله ملك السماوات والارض والى الله
المصير
الم تر ان الله يسجي سحابا ثم يؤلف بينه
ثم يجعله ركاما فترى الودق يخرج من خلاله
وينزل من السماء من جبال فيها من برد
فيصيب به من يشاء ويصرفه عمن يشاء
يكاد سنا برقه يذهب بالابصار
يقلب الله الليل والنهار
ان في ذلك لعبره لاولي الابصار
والله خلق كل دابه
من ماء
فمنهم من يمشي على بطنه ومنهم من يمشي على
رجلين ومنهم من يمشي على اربع يخلق الله
ما يشاء
ان الله على كل شيء قدير
لقد انزلنا ايات مبينات والله يهدي من
يشاء الى صراط مستقيم
ويقولون امنا بالله بالرسول واطعنا ثم
يتولى فريق منهم من بعد ذلك وما اولئك
بالمؤمنين
واذا دعوا الى الله ورسوله ليحكم بينهم
اذا فريق منهم معرضون
وان يكن لهم الحق ياتوا اليه مذعلين
افي قلوبهم مرض ام ارتابوا ام يخافون ان
يحيف الله عليهم ورسوله
بل اولئك
هم الظالمون
انما كان قول المؤمنين اذا دعوا الى الله
ورسوله ليحكم بينهم ان يقولوا سمعنا
واطعنا
واولئك
هم المفلحون
ومن يطع الله ورسوله ويخشى الله ويتقه
فاولئك هم الفائزون
واقسموا بالله جهد ايمانهم لئن امرتهم
ليخرجن
قل لا تقسموا طاعه معروفه ان الله خبير
بما تعملون
قل اطيعوا الله واطيعوا الرسول فان تولوا
فانما عليه ما حمل وعليكم ما حملتم
وان تطيعوه تهتدوا
وما على الرسول الا البلاغ المبين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
ورحمه ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
وعد الله الذين امنوا منكم وعملوا
الصالحات ليستخلفنهم
في الارض كما استخلف الذين من قبلهم
وليمكن كنن لهم دينهم الذي ارتضى لهم
وليبدلنهم
من بعد خوفهم امنا يعبدونني لا يشركون بي
شيئا ومن كفر بعد ذلك فاولئك
هم الفاسقون
واقيموا الصلاه واتوا الزكاه واطيعوا
الرسول لعلكم ترحمون
لا تحسبن الذين كفروا معجزين في الارض
وماواهم النار ولبئس المصير
يا ايها الذين امنوا ليستاذنكم
الذين ملكت ايمانكم والذين لم يبلغوا
الحلم منكم ثلاث مرات
من قبل صلاه الفجر وحين تضعون ثيابكم من
الظهيره ومن بعد صلاه العشاء
ثلاث عورات لكم ليس عليكم ولا عليهم جناح
بعدهن
طوافون عليكم بعضكم على بعض كذلك يبين
الله لكم الايات والله عليم حكيم
واذا بلغ الاطفال منكم الحلم فليستاذنوا
كما استاذن الذين من قبلهم
كذلك يبين الله لكم اياته والله عليم حكيم
والقواعد من النساء
التي لا يرجون نكاحا فليس عليهن جناح
فليس عليهن جناح ان يضعن ثيابهن غير
متبرجات
بزينه وان يستعفن خير
والله سميع عليم
ليس على الاعمى حرج ولا على الاعرج حرج
ولا على المريض حرج ولا على انفسكم
ولا على انفسكم ان تاكلوا من بيوتكم او
بيوت ابائكم
او بيوت امهاتكم او بيوت اخوانكم او بيوت
اخواتكم
او بيوت اعمامكم او بيوت عماتكم او بيوت
اخوالكم او بيوت خالاتكم او ما ملكتم
مفاتحه او صديقكم
ليس عليكم جناح ان تاكلوا جميعا او اشتاتا
فاذا دخلتم بيوتا فسلموا على انفسكم تحيه
من عند الله مباركه طيبه كذلك يبين الله
لكم الايات لعلكم تعقلون
انما المؤمنون الذين امنوا بالله ورسوله
واذا كانوا معه على امر جامع لم يذهبوا
حتى يستاذنوه
ان الذين يستاذنون كاولئك
الذين يؤمنون بالله ورسوله
فاذا استاذنوك لبعض شانهم فاذن لمن شئت
منهم واستغفر لهم الله
ان الله غفور رحيم
لا تجعلوا دعاء الرسول بينكم كدعاء بعضكم
بعضا قد يعلم الله الذين يتسللون منكم
لواذا فليحذر الذين يخالفون عن امره ان
تصيبهم فتنه او يصيبهم عذاب اليم
الا ان لله ما في السماوات والارض قد يعلم
ما انتم عليه
ويوم يرجعون اليه فينبئهم بما عملوا والله
بكل شيء عليم
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تبارك الذي نزل
الفرقان على عبده ليكون للعالمين نذيرا
الذي له ملك السماوات والارض ولم يكن ولم
يتخذ ولدا ولم يكن له شريك في الملك وخلق
كل شيء
وخلق كل شيء فقدره تقديرا
واتخذوا من دونه الهه لا يخلقون شيئا وهم
يخلقون
ولا يملكون لانفسهم ضرا ولا نفعا ولا
يملكون موتا ولا حياه ولا نشورا
وقال الذين كفروا ان هذا الا افك افتراه
واعانه عليه قوم اخرون
فقد جاؤوا ظلما وزورا
وقالوا اساطير الاولين اكتتبها فهي تملى
عليه بكره واصيلا
قل انزله الذي يعلم السر في السماوات
والارض انه كان غفورا رحيما
وقالوا ما لهذا الرسول ياكل الطعام ويمشي
في الاسود واق
لولا انزل اليه ملك فيكون معه نذيرا او
يلقى اليه كنز او تكون له جنه ياكل منها
وقال الظالمون ان تتبعون الا رجلا مسحورا
انظر كيف ضربوا لك الامثال فضلوا فلا
يستطيعون سبيلا تبارك تبارك الذي ان شاء
ويجعل لك قصورا
بل كذبوا بالساعه واعتدنا لمن كذب
بالساعرا
اذا راتهم من مكان بعيد سمعوا لها تغيظا
وزفيرا
واذا القوا منها مكانا ضيقا مقربين دعوا
هنالك ثبورا لا تدعوا اليوم ثبورا واحدا
وادعوا ثبورا كثيرا
قل اذلك خير ام جنه الخلد التي وعد
المتقون
كانت لهم جزاء
ومصيرا
لهم فيها ما يشاء
ون خالدين
كان على ربك وعدا مسؤولا
ويوم يحشرهم وما يعبدون من دون الله فيقول
اانتم اضللتم عبادي هؤلاء
ام هم ضلوا السبيل
قالوا سبحانك ما كان ينبغي لنا ان نتخذ من
دونك من اولياء
ولكن متعتهم
ولكن متعتهم واباءهم
حتى نسوا الذكر وكانوا قوما بورا فقد
كذبوكم بما تقولون فما تستطيعون صرفا ولا
نصرا ومن يظلم منكم نذقه عذابا كبيرا
ما ارسلنا قبلك من المرسلين الا انهم
لياكلون الطعام ويمشون في الاسواق
وجعلنا بعضكم لبعض فتنه اتصبرون
وكان ربك بصيرا
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
ورحمه الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
ان شاء
الشفع والوتر
استووادوا
ركعه
تسليم
الله
اكبر سبحانك اللهمك وتبارك اسمك وتدك وت
خيرك اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم
الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
[Arabic recitation]
ان
الانسان
لفي خسر
والعصر ان الانسان لفي خسر الا الذين
امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وعملوا الصالحات وتواصوا بالحق وتواصوا
بالصبر
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
ايا اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم
ويل لكل همزه لمزه
الذي جمع مالا
وعددا
يحسب ان ماله
اخلدا
كلا لينبذن
في الحطمه
وما
ادراكما الحطم
نار الله الموقدا
التي تطلع على الافئده
انها
عليهم مؤصدا
في عمد
ممددا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن
قل هو الله احد
الله الصمد
لم يلد ولم يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت
وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك لنا فيما
اعطيت
وقنا شر ما قضيت
فانك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
وانه
لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت
ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحان الملك القدوس
سبحان
الملك القدوس
‏We had a good day today,